wir haben das versprechen abgegeben dass
wir bei bild weiterhin schauen werden
dass wir nicht wegschauen dass das nicht
diese fälle in münster und auch alles
was jetzt im in der weiteren
ermittlungen des falls medien rauskommt
dass wir das nicht einfach nur berichten
werden und darüber hinweg gehen werden
und nach allen nach ein paar tagen ist
dann alles wieder so wie vorher
sondern dass wir wirklich dranbleiben
dass wir wirklich laut sagen wie wir zum
thema kindesmissbrauch stehen dass wir
das mit sehr großen buchstaben auch
weiter schreiben so lange bis eben
gesetzeslücken geschlossen sind bis sich
die politik bewegt dann immer noch gilt
kindesmissbrauch oder wird vielerorts in
vielen vielen fällen als vergehen nicht
als verbrechen gewertet und es gibt auch
anders als beispielsweise bei
steuerhinterziehung nicht diese ganz
klaren fall wenn kindesmissbrauch
vorliegt dann ist in jedem fall eine
haftstrafe zu verhängen nämlich es ist
immer noch wie wir heute oder gestern
abend aus bückeburg erfahren haben
häufig gibt es richter die täter auf
bewährung draußen lassen und wir sagen
ganz klar kindesmissbrauch da kann keine
bewährung stattfinden
und wie gesagt wir sagen das so laut bis
sich die politik bewegt und dort scheint
sich mittlerweile ein bisschen was zu
tun wir hören jetzt von cdu
generalsekretär paul signac dass die cdu
und er im ganz persönlichen oder ganz
besonderen drastische strafen fordert im
fall von kindesmissbrauch wir haben
jetzt bei uns zugeschaltet paul zehn
jahren drastische strafen was genau wo
genau werden wenn sie es durchsetzen die
strafen härter gesamten bereich des
kindesmissbrauchs und auch der
verbreitung und den besitz von
kinderpornografie stärker unter strafe
stellen dh ich fordere dass diese
straftaten zu verbrechen erklärt werden
und nicht zu vergeben so wie es bisher
ist ich verstehe nicht warum die
bundesjustizministerin sich weigert
diesen weg mit uns zu gehen das hat auch
mit der abwägung von rechtsgütern zu tun
wir haben andere straftatbestände
beispielsweise im bereich des diebstahls
oder im bereich des
betäubungsmittelhandel
wo es ganz andere mindeststrafen gibt wo
verbrechen eben erkannt werden zu recht
erkannt werden da spricht man nicht nur
von mindeststrafen von unter einem jahr
sondern sogar von nicht unter fünf
jahren und dort haben wir eben
nachholbedarf ich halte es für absolut
an der zeit dass wir jetzt das recht
ändern das strafrecht ändern und
appelliere an die bundesjustizministerin
jetzt diesen weg zu gehen und auch
andere verschärfungen einzuführen
beispielsweise auch leichter
untersuchungshaft zu verhängen das ist
ganz ganz wichtig und wir brauchen
bewegung im bereich der
vorratsdatenspeicherung damit wird die
täter ermitteln können und wir brauchen
eine öffentliche diskussion darüber in
allen medien die sie jetzt gerade führen
und die ich jetzt bei bild verfolgen
konnte das ist wichtig dass dieses thema
mitten in der öffentlichkeit ist wie
alle und nicht nur politisch sondern
auch medien haben eine verantwortung
dass wir das zu einer großen
gesellschaftlichen debatte machen damit
so schnell wie möglich jetzt die
änderungen kommen ja ganz genau lassen
wir uns dieser verantwortung gemeinsam
gerecht werden er zehn jahre trotzdem
noch einmal aufgedröselt und vielleicht
auch für den verständlich gemacht die
jetzt nicht jeden tag im strafgesetzbuch
nachlesen das heißt was genau bedeutet
das wenn eben kindesmissbrauch in keinem
fall mehr als vergehen gewertet wird
sondern immer als verbrechen was
bedeutet dass mit blick auf die
haftstrafen
das bedeutet dass das gericht keine
andere möglichkeit hat als mindestens
ein jahr gefängnis zu verurteilen eben
das ist ganz ganz wichtig bisher haben
wir sechs monate das ist ein vergehen
es muss zu einem verbrechen erklärt
werden damit es ein mindestmaß an
strafen gibt aus meiner sicht mindestmaß
an vertretbarer strafe gerichte haben
immer noch ganz viele andere
möglichkeiten dort auf den einzelfall
einzugehen aber wir brauchen diesen
verbrechenstatbestand ich sage in allen
bereichen
das betrifft eben die verbreitung den
besitz auch das handeltreiben mit
kinderpornografischen materialien aber
auch den missbrauch als sollte noch mal
wir haben das in anderen bereichen wie
ich finde zu recht aber es ist niemandem
zu erklären
das beim handeltreiben mit
betäubungsmitteln es 1 1 das zum
verbräuchen erklärt wird und beim thema
kindesmissbrauch kinderpornografie nicht
okay das ist ein wichtiger schritt jetzt
wissen wir bei steuerhinterziehung
beispielsweise dass die abnehm bestimmte
ausmaß des vergehens daneben auch keine
bewährungsstrafe mehr erhalten dürfen
wie sieht das wenn sie es durchsetzen
mit blick auf kindesmissbrauch aus kann
kindesmissbrauch auch weiterhin zu einer
bewährungsstrafe führen sie haben sie
gerade von roll ringer dass wir dass die
gerichte und dann der gesetzgeber
genügend möglichkeiten haben ich finde
persönlich dass es dort keine
bewährungsstrafe geben kann weil diese
verbrechen so schlimm sind wir sprechen
da nicht von von von delikten eins von
vielen sondern kinder die missbraucht
wurden sind gekennzeichnet und in den
meisten fällen für ihr ganzes leben
sie kriegen keine bewährung sie sind
bestraft für ihr ganzes leben
der gesetzgeber kann für die gerichte
aus dem schaffen so wie es in anderen
delikten auch in diesem bereich der fall
ist wenn es sich wirklich zeigen sollte
dass die schuld eines täters und die tat
ein solches ganz anders ist als der
gesetzgeber den normalen fall angenommen
hat aber ich sage wer kinder missbraucht
der schädigt sie für ihr ganzes leben
und deswegen brauchen wir es als
verbrechen im strafgesetzbuch und vor
allem keine zu weichen strafen und
bewährungsstrafen ich will da einmal
noch mal ganz kurz dranbleiben herz der
aktion fall wie wir den jetzt aus
bückeburg gehört haben ja ein lehrer
missbraucht seinen eigenen sohn und die
härtere strafe wird später noch einmal
aufgehoben und dann zur bewährung
ausgesetzt wird nach dem konzept was sie
jetzt vorlegen wollen vorlegen werden
eine solche abbildung der strafe noch
möglich sein
ich kenne den fall nicht im einzelnen
ich habe heute die berichterstattung
gelesen ich will mich nicht zu einzelnen
fällen äußern aber fälle solcher art
müssen zwingend nicht nur am anfang mit
untersuchungshaft beginnen sondern dann
auch in einer haftstrafe
regierung in sie haben eingangs auch
schon über die beschaffung über den
besitz von kinderpornografischem
material gesprochen
auch da wollen sie noch einmal
verschärfen inwiefern ja auch daten geht
es um den strafräumen und die
mindeststrafen und da gilt das gleiche
wie beim missbrauch selbst warum jetzt
mögen sich einige fragen na ja das sind
doch zwei unterschiedliche dinge
aber das eine bedingt das andere wenn
menschen dieses diese schlimme material
was menschen eben für ganzes leben auch
geschädigt hat nicht konsumieren würden
nicht weiter verkaufen würden nicht
besitzen würden es gar nicht haben
wollten dann würde es auch aller
voraussicht nach nicht in diesem umfang
wie wir sie jetzt erleben durch die
ermittlungen produziert werden das eine
bedingt das andere
deswegen wer kindesmissbrauch im bereich
der kinderpornografie bekämpfen will der
muss natürlich den konsum den besitz des
handel treiben ganz strengen unter
strafe stellen jetzt die vielleicht
entscheidende frage für das was am ende
hinten rauskommt also es schön und gut
wenn zehn jahre will und wenn die cdu
will aber die ganze regierung muss es
wollen und der bundestag muss am ende
das gesetz verabschieden kriegen sie die
justiz ministerin überzeugt kommt das
ding durch den bundestag
ich bin momentan etwas ratlos und
sprachlos warum die justizministerin das
nicht möchte es gibt kein einziges
wirklich schlüssiges argument wirklich
schlüssiges argument dagegen
wir fordern dass es muss auch in diesem
jahr passieren das darf nicht auf die
lange bank geschoben werden nochmal
deswegen bin ich wirklich halte ich es
für richtig dass auch medial so
berichtet wird über dieses thema und wir
werden das zu einem thema machen in der
koalition und dann hoffe ich von unserem
koalitionspartner dass er das so sieht
wie wir das beim kindesmissbrauch ist
keine falsche toleranz geben darf also
die cdu-chefin nämlich an sowieso die
haben sie schon an bord die kanzlerin
auch also ich hab ich kann das sagen
erstens hatte annegret kramp-karrenbauer
das ja bereits am montag deutlich
gemacht
von statements zweiter das was ich spüre
aus der cdu und csu
sowohl aus der bundesregierung als auch
aus der fraktion gibt es große
unterstützung dafür weil wir dieses
problem sehen übrigens die cdu hat das
schon seit langem gefordert ist es immer
wieder am justizministerium gescheitert
sowohl wir in der bundestagsfraktion als
auch herbert reul beispielsweise als
innenminister aber viele andere
innenminister auch haben das zum thema
gemacht und mein appell an das
justizministerium ist jetzt den weg frei
zu machen für eine verschärfung des
gesetzes aber diese verschärfung ist vor
allem schutz für die die am meisten
schutz brauchen nämlich kinder in
unserem land herzlich merck letzte frage
ein bisschen persönlicher sie selbst
sind papa sie haben auch lange in
münster gelebt dort wo die ermittlungen
dazu geführt haben die wirklich den
größten fall von kindesmissbrauch in der
geschichte der bundesrepublik dann
aufzudecken und am wochenende damit an
die öffentlichkeit zu gehen
lassen sie uns ein bisschen in ihr herz
schauen und vielleicht aber auch darauf
was in münster noch passieren muss denn
da gab es ein jugendamt was ganz
offenbar ja drastische fehleinschätzung
vorgenommen hat um es ganz vorsichtig zu
formulieren und es gab nachbarn die
wahrscheinlich weggeschaut haben
erzieher lehrer denen ganz offenbar
nichts aufgefallen ist oder die
weggeschaut haben
es gab ja vor in nordrhein-westfalen
muss man sagen auch vor diesem fall hat
der innenminister aber treu das ja zur
chefsache gemacht hat entsprechend
personal und kapazitäten aufgerüstet
dass überhaupt solche ermittlungen dann
auch in der form so erfolgreich sein
können und dafür bin ich ihm auch ganz
persönlich dankbar
wie geht es einem wenn man familienvater
ist glaube ich wie den meisten anderen
menschen die diese nachrichten sehen als
politiker lernt man ja das eine oder
andere zu formulieren und schnell auf
etwas zu reagieren aber bei diesen bei
diesen dingen fehlen mir einfach die
worte
logischerweise stellt man sich vor
mensch das sind kinder die in einem
vielleicht ähnlichen alter sind wie die
eigenen kinder
wie kann ein mensch anderen menschen an
und kindern und zum teil ja sogar
eigenen kindern oder stift kindern so
etwas antun das ist eine mischung
natürlich aus völliger sprachlosigkeit
mitgefühl
weil ich mich frage jetzt unabhängig von
der juristischen bewertungen der
politischen debatte die wir jetzt haben
was wird aus den kindern welche
unterstützung bekommen sie wir brauchen
auch da in diesem bereich mehr
unterstützung und prävention mitgefühl
und natürlich die sehnsucht danach dass
wir alles tun damit möglichst sich diese
fälle nicht wiederholen und ich sage das
thema vorratsdatenspeicherung lassen sie
mich das hinzufügen ich kenne die ganzen
akademischen diskussionen in diesem
bereich aber wir werden im bereich der
kinderpornographie die ja häufig im netz
im internet gehandelt wird werden wir
nur erfolge erzielen können wenn wir
auch beim thema der
vorratsdatenspeicherung erfolge erzielen
die wieder auf die agenda setzen und das
tun es ist es wert und kinder zu
schützen bei aller akademischen
diskussion da muss etwas passieren
danke paul zehn jahre für diese zuletzt
emotionalen worte und dann aber allen
vor allen dingen für die ankündigung
dass die cdu schon mal an bord ist um
drastische strafverschärfung
durchzusetzen bei kindesmissbrauch das
nehmen wir mit
an diesem mittwochmittag moritz also die
cdu es an bord und unser versprechen
führt dann dahin das wird aber weiter am
ball bleiben und jetzt eben auch schauen
dass das umgesetzt wird das ist die
justizministerien reicht und dann auch
den bundestag drastische verschärfung
mit blick auf kindesmissbrauch also
druck darauf dass dieses gesetz
verschärft wird ganz wichtig aber du
hast es ja auch angesprochen die
aufklärung ist so wichtig dass die
jugendämter hinschauen was in den
familien passiert und diese dann auch
diese fälle an die öffentlichkeit kommen
und fuß gericht teilweise ganz
herzlichen dank